horner bar management is bringing new
meaning to ordering a cold one on
fremont street their new bar opening
this week's there's house made waffle
cones and cocktails that's my kind of
place here's rocky with a preview
we have the perfect weather right now
here in las vegas so we all scream for
ice cream a party a drink and you can
get it right here at the newest
nightlife destination on fremont street
here in downtown it is called we all
scream and michael you brought this
block a lot of bars and a lot of
nightlife destinations so what made you
bring this one to town well this is art
infused two-story nightclub and add to
it we've got ice creamery oh my gosh so
what can we let's walk over to the ice
cream real quick because you can
literally walk in here and order some
ice cream at the parlor and then get
your drink at the bar so what kind of
flavors are we talking about we got
fluffy nutella we've got a sweet georgia
caramel i think my favorite one is
frozen hot chocolate oh my god are you
gonna have any like coffee ice cream
that's my favorite top secret okay fine
okay just call it the rocky
las vegas now okay so let's talk about
the bar concept now you know what kind
of drinks are we are we enjoying here
we're going to have some specialty
cocktails it's going to be
candy infused ok i think cotton candy
put ice creamery in with alcohol and
we're going to have a good time i love
it and of course the decor in here is so
fun
what inspired you guys when you were
decorating or designing this place we
really wanted to add to the downtown
scene
everything is hand painted by
international artists from spain and
brazil
wow that's really cool and wednesday is
the big night it's grand opening what's
the plan may 4th grand opening
doors are at 11 30. you can sign up to
get in at we allscream.com okay and what
are you most excited about for wednesday
and just the future of this place i
can't wait to show it off this has been
a work in progress for a couple of years
and i think we've got a lot to be proud
of so i can't wait for everybody to hear
the dj booth see what we've created and
enjoy themselves okay well speaking of
dj booths we're going to show you those
coming up and they are
unique i should say so stay tuned